Alright. Welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today,
have another episode of Clustered.
Woo hoo.
Feel free to say hello in the comment
section. I'll pop them up on the screen.
My name is David Flanagan, but I go
by the handle Rawkode.
And today we have a solo edition of
clusters. So we've got two great guests with
us with two broken clusters that we will
attempt to fix.
Remember, it doesn't matter how our guests fix
the clusters, all you need to do is
get that v two image running,
which I've made some fixes this week. I
haven't added logging, but I forgot.
But I hopefully have
introduced enough cache busting
so that we'll actually see v two without
10,000 refreshes
or at least fingers crossed.
Okay. Before we get started, there's a little
bit of housekeeping where I wanna thank our
sponsors. Teleport have been sponsoring Custard for a
very long time now, and we've been using
Teleport since the very first episode. You see
it in action every single week. It is
an amazing tool that allows you to commoditize
and secure
the access to your Linux machines, Kubernetes clusters,
applications
and databases.
So you'll see us using it, Go check
it out by visiting rokode.live/teleport.
And also thank you to Equinix Metal. They
provide all of the hardware. We run clustered
on bare metal machines with, I think, like
32 cores and 60, maybe even a hundred
gig of RAM. I can't remember. They're pretty
big beefy boxes. Why?
Well, because it makes it more fun. So
thank you to EquinixMetal for that as well.
Now I'm gonna pop over and introduce our
guests, and then we'll get the comments going,
and then we'll fix some broken clusters.
Alright. Welcome, guest. Today, I am joined by
Rawkode and.
Hi there. How are you both?
Hello.
Alright.
Yeah. I don't know if he's nervous or
excited or a little bit of both,
but let's start with some introductions
there. Barco, why don't you go first? Tell
us who you are, and then we'll move
over.
Hi. My name is Barco.
I'm currently working
as a software engineer at RenderCloud.
Big fan of the cluster series. I think
it's a great resource for people learning Kubernetes.
So I'm happy and humbled to be here
and try and fix some clusters.
Yeah. You also participate in officers with me,
sharing more Kubernetes knowledge with everyone. So thank
you for that as well.
Alright.
Bojan?
Yeah. Hello. Nice
to meet you. And,
yeah, I'm a software engineer
at Digital Ocean.
Is my identical twin brother, so it's a
quintessential
twin thing that we're working at the computing
companies, I guess.
And
not really super familiar with this show. I've
only watched it once when participated
once before.
And but, yeah, looking forward to, I guess,
trying to fix what he did.
And
yeah. Maybe a little bit of expectation setting.
I think mostly what I do is
interacting
with Kubernetes programmatically.
So, you know, manually configuring control plane is
not something I do on a regular basis.
So maybe I don't have the operational muscle
memory
for
everything involved there. But, yeah, looking forward to
learning maybe something new myself as well.
Awesome. Well, thank you very much for sharing.
This is the first ever identical twins we've
had on custard, so that's pretty cool.
And we're gonna see if the twin tuition.
Is that a thing? Right? Twin tuition? You
both can just read each other's mind now?
I think we have found that not to
be true, I think. Would you agree, Rawkode?
I don't know.
Alright.
Well, we're gonna find out if you could
protect each other's breaks. So I'm gonna pop
open
my screen share here. I'm gonna pause the
timer just because we're not quite ready. I'm
not even decided who's going first.
We have our teleport server here. Does do
either of you have a preference for going
first? Yeah. Barcode, you suggested. Right? So Yeah.
Let's pop open
control plan.
I'm gonna start the timer.
Okay. If you could please join the session.
Just type echo hello, anything to let us
know that you're there. Start setting up your
KubeConfig, and we'll take it from there.
You guys see that? We do indeed. Good
luck. Awesome.
Okay.
So first thing I'm gonna do is
get my completion.
No. Even setting up the KubeConfig first. It's
just like I want my auto complete. Just
Mhmm.
Yeah.
Is that okay? Yep.
Alright.
And then we will
So first thing I'm gonna do is just
check if we have nodes
or
namespaces,
and things seem to be I mean, we're
connecting
to the cluster. Yeah. You've got a healthy
control plan.
A good start.
So we don't have our application running.
Let's see if we have
I mean, things seem to be okay.
Okay. So I will
so here we have
so we have invalid
image
name.
Yep.
So I'm guessing he
so it just to explain things, this is
a deployment.
So we can see that there's a deployment.
So we'll take
a so we'll take a
look at this deployment.
And take a look at if he changed
the image.
Is that
I I feel like that's probably not correct.
Is that supposed to be the right?
Yeah. So it has been updated to the
Rawkode Academy GitHub organization now rather than my
Rawkode username. So that does look
alright. Yeah. That looks fine.
Okay. Interesting.
It passes the a test, at least. I'm
not telling you it's correct, but I'm gonna
say that it looks correct.
So
I don't think we've seen invalid image name
before Yeah. On cluster.
That's not a, like,
image pulling error. So I'm trying to think
what does that quite mean.
I'm also curious. Are you on a vertical
screen by any chance?
No. No. No. Or just a very large
screen? Like, your screen is massive compared to
mine.
Alright. It doesn't matter. I'm I'm scrolling frantically
to keep up. But
there anything I can do here to fix
it? No. We're we're we're all good. It's
all good. Don't worry about it, mate.
So
just because I'm I'm curious about what we're
seeing. Right? Is that we have two clustered
replica sets here or at least two pods
with different replica IDs.
So it's as if the image has been
updated.
It's now being considered invalid
by the kubelet.
But when you go to the deployment spec,
it it doesn't appear to have been modified.
Right. And the image pull policy is always
Let's
take out
the sledgehammer
already.
Oh, there's lots.
The sledgehammer's coming out.
So you're gonna delete all the replica sets
and force the deployment to recreate. I'm
not going to be trying to figure out
if that's a cause of the issue
or not.
What's the l equals clustered.
I'm not sure if dash dash label
Oh. Work. But dash l one l. Well,
one dash.
And a d on custard.
Oh.
Sorry. It's the it's the rule of typing
when people are watching. Right?
Okay.
Wow. Image name.
I mean, this is Oh, yeah. I was
laughing at it. Is there idea.
Why don't we just describe the pod? Is
there maybe there's something else in the event?
Yeah.
Failed to apply default image
tag.
I mean, this sounds something like container d.
Like, something's different. Like, I almost feel like
something's
off there.
I don't know. I have never seen this
here before,
but invalid reference format. Right? Like, that
for some reason,
my inclination
is saying that it's not Kubernetes.
What what were you what do you think?
So it's fact field.
I mean,
it passes
the eye test, and I've been burned by
this before on clustered.
I'm
half tempted
to guess that there's maybe a Unicode character
in that image name.
It's
kinda where my my brain that has been
hurt in the past by breakers is going
to right now.
So I mean,
what I would do would be to edit
the deployment again and retype that whole image
name from scratch.
Okay. Yeah. Let's do that.
I mean, it's just a guess. Like, I
I'm wrong more often than I'm right. So
it's
your call.
Well, Robert Cable said, is that even a
valid URL? It certainly looks valid,
and
Russell
is saying that the Unicorn is against the
rules. Only unofficially. It's never become an
official rule.
Like like the no e b p f
rule. Like, you can use e b p
f. It's not not a real rule. Why
did that jump over?
Sometimes when does that, it's particularly annoying.
Abhishek is saying why people talk very low
about DevOps.
I can talk louder if that's what you
mean. I'm not sure. Hey.
Okay.
That's interesting.
Does it still stay invalid?
Well, I updated it to v two because
that's the goal, and we type the image
names. So I don't know. I mean, things
seem to be working. So
can we open the page and see if
the I suspect we have more things to
fix. But
Sure. Hopefully
hopefully, my breaks are correct.
Yes. We have a database connection time out.
So You want I was using the only
code in there. If that if that was
against the rules, my apologies. I didn't know.
But It's it's not against the rule. It's
an unofficial rule because
it hurt me so much last time. I
literally spent
thirty or forty minutes
pulling my hair out. I have no idea.
So it's it's not against the rules. You
can use it. Or something.
Was it the k? Because I thought the
k looked It was it was the c.
The c was the serialic c or the
serialic s, I guess. Yeah. So It was
the c last time as well. So that's
just that hurt even more. But there we
go.
Alright. So we've got a v two,
but we cannot reach the database.
So the issue is now your application needs
to connect to our database.
And if I recall correctly, that's hard coded
in the application. Correct? It is hard coded,
yep, as Postgres.
Right. Okay. So let's
that stateful set.
Yep. That stateful set called PostgresQL
just to make it more annoying.
But the service is Postgres. I should fix
that too.
So you're going straight into the service definition.
Yeah. I just want to see if there
there was something off here because
last time I was in Cluster, they put
a startup probe to change the password. So
I thought maybe he was doing the same
thing back to me.
But there doesn't seem to be a startup
probe that's
that's doing anything.
Is that correct? Redness probe?
That
looks alright to me.
If that were failing, the pods would not
be healthy. Right. And I think the pod
was healthy.
Yeah. Correct. Okay.
So I'm just going to take a look
at our
pods and services
and endpoints.
It looks good.
Yeah.
Got a service. Got an IP address. We've
got an endpoint.
Okay.
Did you say we have logging now or
something? No. I didn't add logging.
Oh. I I added cache and validation so
that when we deploy v two, we'll actually
see the video rather than the browser. Because
I used the same video name on both.
It should be it should work better now.
So Okay. What would cause the
cluster pod to be unable to speak to
the Postgres pod?
Let's check if there's any network policies.
Yeah. Good idea.
This is a Selium cluster. How's your Selium
knowledge?
Terrible.
Yeah. So I'm just checking,
like, what other network policies
may
exist.
So we have some
ceiling specific network policies.
Yes. We have CMP and CCNP,
which are cluster cluster
network policies and cluster
cluster wide network policies.
Is that correct?
I don't think so. Right?
Well, I think we need to take a
look at it.
Yeah. I mean, I'm I'm just going to
get that.
Yes. We have an Anchorage deny on app
cluster to Port 5432. Yeah. That would probably
get in the way of things, wouldn't it?
Oh,
there's that too.
You can just do CCNP
as a sharp or, yeah, tap to put
that out. That works.
Okay.
Maybe let's give it another try.
I'm afraid that it's still unable to connect
to the database.
And I I love the laughter on the
face there.
So what we had some other policies maybe
we should Yeah. There's also CNPs.
And there's our first DNS comment on the
chat from Bradley.
Okay. So
We pointed out that the error message was
slightly different.
Oh, was it Failed to look up address.
So yeah. So this was not a failure
to connect. This was a failure to look
up address. Good catch there, Bradley. I don't
know if that So
this sounds like DNS.
So if I
I think it's in the config map.
No.
Right. Is that where the DNS might be
configured?
There is a conflict map called core DNS,
and they could just have namespace. Yep.
Bradley has seen the previous Unicode break
where Guy Templeton
put the Unicode c and stayed
resolver for the Kubernetes namespace. Yeah. So I
I see something here that does not look
right.
What do you see?
Yeah.
Right. Yeah.
So let's fix that.
You don't like that rewrite then?
I do not.
Would you like me to or that?
What what do you want me to do?
You want me to try again?
Yeah.
Alright. Look up failed.
Did I okay.
This is actually a question we get on
officers a lot, if that helps you.
I modified a config map. Oh, we got
we got we got to restart the
Everyone's
biggest gripe with config maps. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, what is this?
That's CT blank control point one. That's not
good. That's okay. That's
that's because it's a matter of pods. So
it inherits the name of the control plan.
Right. Okay.
Yeah. All the comments are coming in there.
Restart, Gordon. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. The
audience are always much better than us than
I am.
Alright. Would you like me to try again?
Let's
yeah. Let's give it another try.
And we have to Dan.
Alright.
That was good. Well done.
I know. Very pragmatic.
It
I think it was good learning
debugging exercise for sure.
Yeah. Definitely.
I got some clever ideas.
I want to try to make the API
servers that are returning, like, I'm a teapot
status code for, like,
image or, like, random stuff, but I can't
get that working. So
Yeah.
I I reckon if I haven't if if
I didn't mention the previous unit code break,
we may have been
looking at that error and valid image name
a bit longer.
You think you would have got the Unicode
given enough time there?
Me? No.
Yeah.
Probably wouldn't have any side of that.
Because there's a truly evil break.
Well done there. Alright. Let's Who is the
evil twin, I guess? We'll find out. Well,
let's say that right now. I'm gonna open
a session on Rawkode.
Control plan one
is now there.
I have shared my screen again.
So,
Rawkode,
if you can
join our So I'm joining yeah. Okay. Join
the session. Just take echo so that we
can see it on the screen. We know
we're in the same session.
Yep. Perfect. And then set up your Kube
config tech for our control plan, and best
of luck.
Oh, the alias key. That's
the season pro right there.
I
don't know about that.
So I don't know. Let's
just
trying to get all the parts, and this
is not looking good.
It is not. I do not think
I think we know if we'll be able
to train now.
Oh, no.
K. That's running.
Alright. So we do have a Kiplit over
the pier.
But there there are some banners. Running.
Now let me just
is it queue?
If we got the the CTL,
system control status, or are you trying to
check something else?
Well, q v p I is here. Where
is it?
Oh, yes. So that runs under a static
manifest, so there won't be a system d
service.
Yeah.
But we do have some error messages
Here. Okay.
Error get
Says our container runtime network is not ready.
Okay.
Never plug in. Oh, okay.
Okay. So c and nine.
I mean, I'd be running.
You can always just use PS to see
what, like, if you a running.
Right? The PS and and filter for Kubernetes
is probably a good step right now.
Because we have no eye no idea what's
running.
So
we have HCD.
I'm going to save for now. That looks
okay.
Yep. We have a scheduler. We have a
controller manager. We have a kubelet.
We do have an HD. I don't see
an API server.
Yeah.
So
yeah.
So that
I guess.
Is that even okay. I mean, should that
be
No. I wouldn't expect to see that there
because it runs inside of container.
So the kiplet is responsible for starting at
c d and the control manager and the
scheduler.
And those all started fine.
So
your next step is maybe to go look
at the static manifest directory.
Yes. And
we do have an API server.
So I guess Untouched fail snaps. Although that
means nothing these days. But still,
Rawkode wouldn't be that mean, would he?
Sorry. We'd
okay. I I don't know. I did break
at CB last time. So
There's some suspicious output right in the middle
of our screen.
I don't know if you see that.
I don't know if I should mention it,
but I have now.
Do you see the process is running?
These looks suspicious. Oh, yeah. I do. Yeah.
Okay.
I know what that is, but, like, I
guess, let's yeah.
Rawkode's like, shit. I've I've been cut. I
can't have said that PS comment.
Okay.
Well, I'm just gonna
oh, wait.
First, I'm going to delete that. Yeah.
That
kinda so the idea was that you'd check
IP tables,
but I have a lock in it so
you can't flash them.
So you'd have to figure out, like, how
to remove the lock
or find this file and just stop the
crunch up or something.
Alright. Yeah. Like, we do IP tables at
Let's do IP tables dash f, capital f,
and see what I've never seen a
lock on it before. A capital f. Sorry.
Oh,
nice.
Even if, yeah, even if you go, like,
flash w,
right, because it's right now running as a
cron job, It would rewrite.
So, like, you might get
you might, like, flash them and be able
to access the best like, delete them, and
then it would recreate them.
Sneaky. Very, very sneaky.
Cool.
So
you've already just kinda given away. This is
the cron, so we're gonna have to edit
the system cron to stop the script.
So I I have
You can do crontab dash e. It'll drop
again. It's straight in. Yeah.
So
I have seen, like, this error
in in, like, live,
which is kind of it was inspired
by, like, an instant I had to deal
with previously.
But it was when you have a lot
of if you're using IP tables,
if you have a lot of rules,
the
the IP tables can get pretty large,
and then they take a while to update.
And then you can have a lot of
if you have a lot of pods or
a lot of things changing quickly,
you can get into some weird behavior where
processes start tearing out because
they time out
trying to update the IP tables where another
process has it.
So I wanted to kinda replicate something similar.
Unfortunately, I couldn't do anything with network
policies because we're using.
So I just kinda had to
just
do a lock on it,
I guess, using the fake command.
Yeah.
It was nice. I like that.
I There's something not working. Let me
oh. There we go. Thank you. There we
go.
Alright. So the crown has been removed.
Maybe we should check the process table just
to make sure this
they're they're actually gone.
That that looks a bit better.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. You wanna check our control
plan again?
Well, the point where IP team will still
be there. So we'll we we will need
to flush them again.
Alright. Now surely we're have a control plan.
Well,
let's just
oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. We still don't have
a API server. Yeah. Well remembered.
No. This
is interesting.
I don't think I broke the UPS server.
Oh, man.
Alright. Oops.
Am I?
So it could just be that with the
the drops on the table, the API server,
maybe under some sort of crashing state.
You could try restarting the kubelet to encourage
it to restart the API server again.
That's I don't know. Oh.
Bradley wants to know, Rawkode, if you changed
the default editor to Nano.
No. I think that's just when you do
cron tap, it, like, asks you what you
want to open. So the default is Nano.
Alright. Okay. So
Well, can you check the IP tables?
We're now getting a connection refused instead of
a timeout, which makes me think the IP
tables
are now working correctly,
but we're not getting the APIs ever started.
So
Let's
run the PS one more time just just
to be sure that we don't see
the API server there.
I see it. Yeah. It says there now.
Okay. Good. So I think it just the
Kubernetes just needed a bit of a bit
of help.
Okay.
So
let me see.
Maybe try to get pods or something and
see if it's actually working.
Yeah. There we go. Alright.
Celeum is crashing.
But, like, I guess
I'm assuming one of our notes is maybe
offline or maybe it's just this node that's
offline and it's just because
it's not restarted those ones yet. I'm not
sure.
Oh, right. Namespace.
Now I'm just going to check.
This looks sane at the
let's see if there's any events.
No status
here.
Okay. Let's just check.
So, yeah, the
Are those are those pods still crash the
back off?
And so one of those come back. I
think if I think if you kick kick
the crash loop back Yeah. They do take
mhmm. I think it's because this node
the API server was offline, and it just
It's cool.
It up, actually.
So it should be sync
three.
Oh my god.
Yeah. Do a wait.
Oh, no. That's a worker one. Okay.
So Potentially,
he's been on worker two,
causing some pain.
No. Okay. But, I mean But we don't
we don't need worker two. Right? So
I I mean, possible
because I did do try to do some
other stuff that might have,
but I don't think
Alright. Our custard pod looks alright. Shall we
shall we try the update?
I mean,
can can we just see whether the app
works? Can you open whether version one works
first, I guess? Yeah. Sure.
Yeah.
Alright. Connection tagged out. Speaking to the database.
Okay.
Which is
interesting.
Okay. We've we've got ceiling working. Okay. So
that's not
okay. That is so that's that's not an
issue anymore.
So yeah. Okay. So we're kinda at the
same problem that he had Yep.
To assume.
Hopefully, he didn't do the same thing I
did.
That'd be very
train intuition type of thing, I guess. Definitely.
So yeah.
Yeah. So
let I mean, Postgres is running.
It does appear to be. Yeah.
Yeah. So let's just,
I guess,
get
Let's take a look at oops.
So
I'm, like, attempted to rewrite the image here,
but I know that's not wrong.
So redness.
I mean, that's fine.
Right? Because there's no
oh,
wait.
Start approved.
That that looks a bit interesting.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's
I think you got
I don't know if it was just intuition
or luck that you described that deployment instead
of looking going down the rabbit hole of
services and endpoints. So that's definitely to intuition
that you went in there. I think so.
Because I wouldn't have got that.
I I would have been debugging the network
stuff.
So that was you setting the domain. So
the postgres lookup was gonna end up its
way down custard.com.
Very sneaky.
Wait. Did I did I delete too much?
I
No. You're I mean You're you're good. That's
fine. Oh, okay.
Let me just make sure this all looks
me go to
the source code and
Make sure this all checks out. Okay. Sorry.
You don't trust trust your brother?
Not in this area. No.
So
I miss
probably speak
yeah. Let try that case. Sure. He's speaking.
How can I
obviously?
I do think that's, like,
my code right now. I think I think
this is alright. Yeah.
Okay. Let's
give it a shot. Oops. What happened?
There should be an error at the top
if it was
or
maybe I was wrong when I said that
you you cut it properly. I think I
might have
deleted
something too much. Yeah. I think you've been
doing it. Click
and delete.
So what's the shortcut to go to the
okay. So
no. No. You didn't delete so much.
Oh, no. You didn't delete enough.
Oh, yeah. The failure threshold looked into the
resources, and I thought it was okay. But
yeah. So we have to delete four more
lanes. Yeah.
And then
Yeah. That that's better. There we go. Okay.
So that should
restart it.
You've got v one?
Oh, awesome. Okay.
So let's now change it.
Okay.
Almost.
Yeah. There's just I
mean, I Well We got V2. Cable stuff
could have taken a really long time. Right?
I did not expect to be discovered so
quickly.
Well, mean, you you you don't even try
to hate it in the process table. They're
like, he ran the PS command and it
was just that rare.
Yeah.
That and that's probably not my forties, so
he was definitely
hitting on a weak spot
here.
Yeah. That was interesting.
Yeah. That was good. It was that was
that was fun. I like that. I mean,
I'm not entirely impressed with the Unicode, but
it's it's now that I I've seen it.
It's good.
I I I really thought the Unicode is
gonna be in the DNS as well all
over again.
Okay.
Well, I guess, not surprising that other others
have come up with that idea. Yeah.
Think you undersold yourself by saying that this
is not the yeah. But Russell's still there.
Nice work. Because then you said you weren't
used to this type of work. Like, you
were you were working through that pretty quickly.
Yeah. So I think you can see the
contrast. Like, I'm more used to, like,
debugging
workload
related things. So that's kinda where I was
gravitating towards, like, things like network policies,
things that would affect functioning of what the
app was supposed to be doing
and and how it was supposed to be
running in its environment rather than the cluster
itself and yeah. Just probably why Barco went
for the Linux route and the the control
plane because
Yeah. Because you you knew that's where he
was weaker. Right?
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I was just
one inspired by, like, the issue that faced,
but I couldn't really I want to get
it through Kubernetes somehow, like, with network policies
or, like,
creating a lot of IP table rules that
way. But,
like, it didn't work with.
And then I was like, okay. Whatever. I'll
just make take a look on it, like,
through a script and then put it in
the cron job.
And then I probably shouldn't have said you
can use PS.
It's running. That's right. That
kinda gave it away because I suspect it
would have taken a longer
time to figure it out, but well. Well,
I felt it only fair to mention the
the script that I put in the PS
consider. I also mentioned the unique codes. So
I think that I I even talked to
match a little bit there.
Alright. Well, thank you both for joining us.
That was really cool. Thank you for taking
the time to to break these clusters and
then to come on and share your knowledge
with the audience. It's it's not easy. Thank
you. So I really appreciate you taking the
time to do that.
Yeah. It was fine. It's fine. Awesome.
Alright. Thank you to everyone in the audience
for your comments and chat throughout. As always,
user always catching things that is missed by
us on Clustered. If you want to join
us on Clustered
and you're feeling brave, then drop me a
Twitter DM or open an issue on Get
Help or email me david@rockode.com.
Thank you to our sponsors, Teleport and Equinix
Medal, and thank you to both our guests.
It was a pleasure having you. I hope
we'll see you both soon. And have
a good day.
Thank you. Cheers. Bye.